[Music]
tonight on Brian Ross investigates
Donald Trump under oath
did he tell the truth when asked about a
convicted felon once time to the Russian
mafia who served as his senior advisor
if he were sitting in the room right now
I really wouldn't know what he looked
like
isn't it true that President Trump knew
convicted Russian mobster Felix aider in
2013 when he made that statement yes
plus the lawyer Trump went after when
she wanted a break to use a breast pump
I may have said that's disgusting I may
have said something else I thought it
was terrible I've been called worse
things on the playground when I was nine
so I don't know people are making such a
big deal about including you mr. Rawls
and our shout out for the reporter who
figured out what started all those
California fires by listening to the
police radio from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City this is
Brian Ross investigates good evening and
welcome tonight Donald Trump under oath
he has so far declined to answer
questions in person under oath from
special counsel robert muller but before
he was president he had to testify under
oath in a lot of lawsuits brought
against him dealing with his real estate
business and now some of what came out
in those lawsuits could affect the
ongoing criminal investigations of Trump
and his business circle we start with
how he answered questions about a twice
convicted felon
by the name of Felix ater a man once
tied to the Russian mafia who became a
senior advisor to Donald Trump among
those on the stage when Donald Trump
announced he was about to build the Soho
Trump Hotel and condo project in New
York City was Felix ater a twice
convicted felon
described as having ties to the Russian
mafia
[Music]
please only swear or affirm to tell the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you God I do
Trump was repeatedly asked about Seder
in a lawsuit involving a different Trump
project in Florida in which Seder was
also involved do you recall when you met
mr. Seder for the first time no many
years ago okay I don't know him well at
all but there was many years ago
then Trump was asked about how he
responded to the BBC when its reporter
asked him about Felix ater you stayed in
bed if I may say so with Felix ater and
he was connected with the Mafia again
John may be your thick but when you have
a signed contract you can't in this
country just break it sometimes will
sign a deal and the partner isn't as
good as we'd like but that does happen
and by the way John I hate to do this
but I do have that big group of people
waiting so I have okay know one last
question please sir I have to live thank
you okay all right then I said let me
show you the hand and things he said you
stayed in bed if I may say so with Felix
aider and he was connected with the
Mafia do you see that I don't think he
was connected to the Mafia he got into a
barroom fight and in fact he was
supposedly very close to the government
of the United States as a witness or
something but I don't think he was
connected to the Mafia he he got into
trouble because he got into a barroom
fight which a lot of people do I don't
because I don't drink but I don't think
he was connected to mafia but you know
again I don't know very well but I don't
think he was connected to the Mafia this
was a BBC reporter who tried to
sensationalize an interview and you know
he had a lot to he had a little fun but
I don't I don't see Felix as being a
member of the Mafia okay now that's
that's your opinion to you that's my
opinion
stories in the Miami Herald the New York
Times and court documents all reflect
that seder was convicted in a Russian
mafia run stock scam do you remember
ever discussing the content of this
article with him
with an Ulster sitter mr. Seder yeah no
I don't remember okay did you ever
discuss at any point issues relating to
the ballroom of the barroom brawl
nothing ever okay about how many times
have you have you conversed with mr.
Seder
over the years over the years if you
could ask not many no man if he were
sitting in the room right now I really
wouldn't know what he looked like you
know that was not true according to the
testimony last week of trumps former
lawyer Michael Kohn over the years
President Trump was asked how many times
he interacted with convicted Russian
mobster
Felix seder in 2013 President Trump
testified that quote not many if he were
sitting in the room right now I really
wouldn't know what he looked like
unquote mr. Cohen as you previously
testified isn't it true that President
Trump knew convicted Russian mobster
Felix Seder in 2013 when he made that
statement yes isn't it true that because
of mr. Saders were relationship to the
Trump Organization that he had an office
in the Trump Tower and on the 26th floor
mr. Trump the 26th floor is important
why because it's mr. Trump's floor so he
had an office on the same floor as
President Trump in fact his office when
he left became my office and on top of
that the Trump Organization actually
printed business cards for Seder
describing him as a senior adviser to
Donald Trump a fact noted by Trevor Noah
on The Daily Show when he used a
broadcast report I had done for ABC News
in fact like Russia he apparently
doesn't even know the state that it
exists at the time of the Moscow deal
Trump executives denied to ABC News that
seder had any current role with Trump to
say he's a senior advisor to mr. Trump
at any point in time would not have been
accurate in my mind's arrow or mr. Trump
might yet say there was given cards by
the Trump Organization calling him a
senior advisor to Donald Trump
[Applause]
Noma come on guys come on it's like this
is the same lie as the Russia one I have
nothing to do with this guy Oh actually
he's my senior advisor and I printed it
in gold that's how I did it I printed in
gold joining us now is the lawyer who we
heard on tape questions a Donald Trump
Jared Beck of Miami and former Trump
Organization executive Barbara rez
author of the book all alone on the 68th
floor mr. Beck let me start with you
when you questioned Donald Trump about
feeding senator did you at that time
think he was telling the truth
well let me say this at the time I took
that deposition you have to realize that
this was in the context of a failed
Trump Fort Lauderdale development that
Donald Trump took his name off of and so
he pulled out of the development and I
represented a number of clients who were
suing to get their money back because
they believed they had been deceived
into investing in the property because
of Donald Trump's name nobody was
thinking about Russians or Trump's
business with Russia or even Donald
Trump becoming president but at the time
of that deposition I was seeking to
explore Donald Trump's business
relationships and we already knew I
already knew at the time that there was
a close relationship between bay rock
the company that Felix aider worked for
and the Trump Organization but when
Donald Trump said at that deposition
that he wouldn't recognize Felix Eider
if he was in the same room as him that
just didn't strike me as credible based
on the fact that we knew that bay rock
and trot the Trump Organization had such
a close connection so he was under oath
when he told you that was that perjury
interview should there be some sanction
for him some charge absolutely if
somebody tells a untruth a flat untruth
under oath and that's the very
definition of perjury
Barbara res let me ask you watching all
this watching the back-and-forth about
Donald Trump who you work with for many
years what's your take on mr. Trump and
his connection to the truth you know in
my experience and my experience is quite
a while ago
he just had probably a lot I mean
everything was the best of the worst and
clearly nothing is the best of the most
in real life so right there he was you
know not saying it's actually true I saw
him talk about things that were not so
very consequential and this was not
under oath but certainly he lied about
things absolutely there was a government
official who was to say I wouldn't
believe him that this tongue were know
realized and I think that pretty much
gives you an idea of what you know
dealing with him was like and what he
was doing again what's not truck mr.
Pres we've got a question from the
control room let say help me Rhonda
moment from our executive producer
Rhonda Rhonda Barbara in all those years
of working with Trump and watching the
Michael Cohen testimony and the Muller
investigation how do you think Donald
Trump is taking all this what do you
think he's he's thinking about all this
that's going around him I would say is
probably very enraged he's not used to
this he's not innocence kind of
treatment is that it was just something
happening that he doesn't want that he
can't quash by the way so I would say
he's probably very angry and you know
you've probably had Chiclets of the
students there it's probably not easy to
talk to right now
Jared Beck let me ask you why do you
think Trump was so eager to distance
himself from Felix Sater well at our
deposition the issue was who was funding
this project and Felix aider was known
to have a very shady past in 2013 when
we took this deposition the New York
Times had run an article about how seder
had been convicted in a money a pump and
dump stock scheme that was connected to
the Mafia and so I just think Trump
didn't
want anything on the record associating
himself or his organization specifically
with someone who had such a known shady
past and a connection to the criminal
underworld some criminal law experts
have suggested that if he was involved
in any way of keeping satyrs name out of
it and applied for bank loans by not
disclosing Saders involvement that could
amount to bank fraud is you think
there's something to that well I'm not a
criminal lawyer I'm a civil lawyer but
you know I think the the real question
is you know if if Trump was applying for
loans and he wasn't disclosing all the
material facts and one of his material
partners was in fact someone like a
fetal Felix a door with the background
that Sater had yes I could see that
rising to the level of a fraud claim and
at this point given the testimony of
kono are you gonna recommend to somebody
there be potential perjury charges
brought against the President of the
United States well you know our
involvement in that litigation has long
since ended I think that you know the
issues are now before Congress I'm gonna
be watching with great interest as I
think most of the country is when mr.
Seder testifies on Capitol Hill and I
think that testimony that comes out of
mr. Saders mouth is going to be very
very interesting it's going to give us
even more of a picture into the actual
relationship that Trump had with him
that's right he testifies next Thursday
by the way we've contacted him through
his lawyer asked him to appear on the
program as well that no response
Barbaro's to get back to you for a
second do you think is there a whole
pattern here of criminality that
underlies the Trump Organization
construction I didn't have much to do
with financing or any of this stuff that
it's coming up now I'm just I don't know
activities I never saw you dealt with
Michael Cohen just briefly more recently
what was that like I wrote an article it
was an out that piece of the counter
news and it was I thought somewhat
flattering the trumpet was just
describing my experiences with him as
the person that working as a woman that
worked in a hot position and right after
that was published I got a call from
Michael and it was kind of like I'm a
Warner I love the doll shop and do you
know that what slender is you know
nothing but libel is and what defamation
is and I said you know Michael I have
people here can I call me back so he
could be he could be a bully I guess he
tried to boy I mean he tried to drag me
with Edward a lawsuit I mean it was was
selling it was ill-conceived I think
Barbara and Jared Beck thank you so much
for joining us and for you mr. Beck this
has been a kind of husband-wife effort
with your wife Elizabeth also
questioning Trump under oath provoking
some remarkable outbursts from mr. Trump
I talked with Elizabeth earlier when you
were face to face it appeared to be a
very contentious session was it mmm it
wasn't my most well I don't know if I
was my most contentious session nobody
cried but I would say it's in my top
five it's part of my preparation I was
reading deposition transcripts of Donald
Trump taken by other lawyers who were
adverse to him and you know those
transcripts were vomitus because okay I
know he's a he's a quasi celebrity he's
been in the news into the 80s and these
people they take his deposition and they
sit down and they said told you this
before they said Oh mr. Trump is such an
honor to be before you today I just want
to ask you a few questions
you know and I'm like who the hell side
are you on buddy okay and they get very
starstruck and I saw this over and over
and over again I saw it with lawyers who
would throw their weight around and act
like bitch
shots and then Donald Trump comes in the
room and they turn into jellyfish he
tried to demean you he tried to deflect
your questions he said they were stupid
questions he asked if you even knew what
you were doing is that just a tactic you
know what he's doing I mean really okay
I've been called worse things on the
playground when I was nine so I don't
know how people are making such a big
deal about including you mr. Ross I want
to get an idea of what it was like to
take the deposition of Donald Trump was
was it was it was it like I said was a
big pain in the ass cuz he ran out of
there it was November 16 my baby was
born in August so I had a
three-month-old baby but I was
breastfeeding and as anybody who's done
that knows you you can't just suddenly
stop he he started screaming that's
disgusting you're disgusting I don't
know why I thought it was disgusting
maybe because it involves tits but it's
it's it's like a dialysis it's a it's a
it's a medical procedure you need to do
it you know he said you're disgusting
you ran out of there what happened is in
the middle of everything
it wasn't breast feed you used the word
breastfeed it was breast pump she wanted
to pump in front of me during a
deposition the way she described it was
that she wanted to take a break so she
could take the Trump out in fact of you
as my lawyer who was there he said I've
never seen anything like it
she wanted to breast pump in front of me
and I may have said that's disgusting I
may have said something else I thought
it was terrible she's a horrible person
knows nothing about me I see her she's
now the great expert at Donald Trump no
I'm not a horrible person I mean I'm a
lot of things but I'm not horrible you
know he and his lawyers started
disseminating all these lies about how
with how I was in a state of undress
really ridiculous ridiculous that was a
lie and all these people automatically
believe them because you know as far as
they're concerned you know it's like he
can do no wrong
which I found very disturbing well so so
bottom line and dealing with Donald
Trump when he's under oath what's the
key to getting the truth out of him
I think intelligence agencies and
military organizations around the world
would love to have the answer to your
question is how do you get a person to
tell the truth
Elizabeth bet thank you very much for
joining us next our shout out for the
reporter who figured out what really
happened those deadly California fires
[Music]
our shadow tonight goes to a dogged
reporter in the San Francisco Bay Area
whose work has helped to uncover what
really happened in several deadly fires
showing they probably could have and
should have been prevented
just last year in 2018 there was the
state's deadliest and most destructive
fire the campfire reporter Matthias
Gaffney known as T in the newsroom was
determined to find out the story of what
happened using a database that archives
police and fire frequencies and I just
started listening right around the time
that they believe the fire started
and sure enough I heard that a
dispatcher get a call
[Applause]
under the high tech power lines there's
a possible power line hazard and they
basically reported that there were wires
down underneath transmission lines
and this is right at the moment that the
campfires believed to have started and
right in the area that the campfire was
believed to have started 26 is funny got
the photo right down
so that was a real big break in finding
out what may be the cause for this fire
the evidence pointing to the state giant
PG&E utility key genie just now I said
that they are probably at fault with
their equipment having a malfunction and
so that was you know just a few days
after the camp fire that we were able to
narrow that down and and show that PG&E
very well could be at fault and beyond
the equipment malfunction Gaffney
determined that PG&E if it followed its
own guidelines should have shut down the
power in such high risk fire conditions
most of those criteria were actually met
prior to the camp fire yet for some
reason they decided to keep the power on
PG&E now has declared bankruptcy saying
it expects to face massive lawsuits two
years earlier in another deadly fire
Gaffney was just as adept in disproving
the notion that city officials in
Oakland were unaware of potentially
dangerous conditions at a huge warehouse
called the ship where dozens of artists
and musicians had taken up residence we
wound up getting police body cam footage
and we found that police officers
routinely were responding there and when
they responded there we found a couple
things out from their body cam footage
one was that the the lead tenant of that
warehouse was saying that no one lived
inside the the warehouse which was not
true and then but we also found that in
one instance two police officers respond
to a call for service and you see them
walking through this maze inside the
warehouse and you can hear one of the
officers say something to the effect of
all it would take is one match in this
place would go up
thirty-six people died in the fire two
of the buildings principle tenants have
been charged criminally in both the city
and the Landlord are facing huge
lawsuits Gaffney's reporting on the ship
fire earned him and his fellow reporters
a Pulitzer Prize and two weeks ago he
joined the San Francisco Chronicle after
being named the journalist of the year
in Northern California by the Society of
Professional Journalists I'm born and
raised in the Bay Area here and I have a
you know family I find it really
impactful to kind of do reporting that
immediately impacts my community and you
know the people I've grown up with and I
love and respect so it's really pretty
rewarding so our shout-out tonight to
Matthias Gaffney that's our program
thanks for joining us good night